a math pet there's a TV Marathon on
today of famous fictional doctors don't
want to watch with me sure who's on
first no he's on second who is yes let
me try that again
who's on first no why not nose first
very strange not no strange is third why
won't you just give me a straight answer
I did pretty sure you didn't well what
what's your question tell me who's on
first
No
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that will attempt to prove what
countless quantum physicists don't
really care about can a Time Lord really
exist
last time we talked about his alien
biology two hearts low body temperature
and the tenth doctors dream eNOS oh my
but on to the next issue
time travel let's face it we all love it
people have basically been fantasizing
about moving backwards in time ever
since we started moving forwards through
it
everything from would that I had a
thymus machinist to bump off that Brutus
years ago to man I should have uploaded
that video of me lip-syncing to Numa
Numa up on YouTube but will we ever find
out if it's possible how would we avoid
all the paradoxes will I ever find that
elusive hot tub time machine so many
questions but that's okay we're here to
look at all the evidence pour over all
the research then handpick the pieces
that sound cool just kidding
kind of okay let's get to it the doctor
can travel back and forth in time at
will with his handy-dandy time machine
it's sadly not a hot tub but a TARDIS
which if you've been living under a
Dalek and don't know stands for time and
relative dimension in space besides
being the biggest merchandising
set-piece ever to have come from a TV
series the TARDIS is an unsuspicious
telephone booth that can move the doctor
through time or space can you hear me
now
good so clearly there's some science
fiction going on here and to prove our
Timelord theory we need to focus on the
science to do that we need to start with
this guy you're probably most familiar
with his work on Facebook where his
head's superimposed next to
inspirational quotes about our place in
the universe you know those quotes that
probably weren't even his but we believe
were because it's on Facebook well
beyond teaching that a dream is a wish
that your heart makes what it's disney
albert einstein showed us a lot about
time including the fact that it can be
deceiving or more specifically he taught
us that time is relative it can change
based on its relation to something else
and with that confusing revelation the
theory of relativity was born to
einstein time is a four
mention beyond length width and height
unfortunately he didn't get a chance to
teach us that the fifth dimension is
love interstellar mmm maybe one day I'll
talk about you
maybe for the first three dimensions we
can choose which way to go
forward or backward for every time we go
up we can always go down for every time
we walk forward we can always walk the
same number of steps backward but for
time we can't choose our direction we
can only go forward that is until we get
in the TARDIS
the TARDIS lets us keep moving forward
and backward in all the dimensions we
already know but it also lets us go
forward and backward in the time
dimension it's like a control V key for
your life shouldn't become a u-tube
let's player in 2009 not just backing on
up how's it goin bros this is mad pad so
is it possible well it turns out I'm
Stein was an OG theorist but hey that's
just a theory a quantum mechanical
paradox theory yeah no wonder his
channel doesn't have that many
subscribers anyway his theory of special
relativity is the basis for all modern
time-travel theories in case you missed
this one in freshman physics his theory
of relativity can be summed up by saying
that the rules of time change the faster
you're traveling what that means is once
you start to travel close to the speed
of light what you reach is a
relativistic speed at this point your
time relative to everybody else starts
to change so that your time is actually
slower than everyone else's it's a very
similar phenomenon to when you're
waiting in line at the DMV we're waiting
for Star Wars to come out time slows to
a crawl anyway because time passes
slower for you when you return to the
rest of the world it's like you've
jumped forward in time only a little
time has passed for you but a lot of
time has passed for everyone else it's
suddenly older than you it's better than
plastic surgery and it makes a lot of
sense with what we see in the TARDIS you
get in you speed away and it looks like
you're moving so fast you must be
traveling close to the speed of light
which is exactly the speed you'd need to
travel through time going forward
realistically we can explain all the
times the TARDIS moves forward through
time using relativity definitely a point
in the Timelords existing column but
that's obviously only half the battle
it's okay then what about going in the
other direction let's talk about going
back the future
no no duck Brown we just did that back
to the past
just just back to the past the problem
is traveling backwards in time it's
really complicated there are theories so
many theories about how it's possible
from cosmic strings to faster than life
neutrinos so where do we start well the
series points us to one theory in
particular at the very beginning of
every episode of Doctor Who the wormhole
it's a hypothetical tunnel that acts
like a shortcut from one point in the
universe to another it could bridge two
completely different universes or two
parts of one universe or even two points
in time a wormhole would allow a
Cyberman for instance to travel from one
point to another faster than the speed
of light by taking a shortcut through
space time via the wormhole whether or
not you really understand the physics of
it it sounds easy right
TARDIS enters tunnel in space comes out
on the other end
wherever that end is but there's a
problem with that as good as the show
makes it look wormholes are actually a
messy business keeping a wormhole stable
enough for anything to actually make it
through would require huge amounts of
what physicists call exotic matter let
me take a moment to read the note I have
for my editor in the script here dear
Thomas please put a picture of matter in
a stripper costume for this moment
love matpat behind the scenes at film
Theory ladies and gentlemen matter in
stripper costumes highbrow YouTube
entertainment exotic matter has all
kinds of bizarre qualities that we're
not going to get into here but let's
really be nice here and give the
Timelords the benefit of the doubt let's
say that the TARDIS is able to maintain
wormhole stability and travel through it
on harm would they actually be able to
get back in time well the answer is both
yes and no the problem with wormholes is
actually less about the how they work
and more about the wind
they were physicists believe that in
theory
actually use a wormhole to travel back
in time to the time that the wormhole
was created want to go back to see that
hilarious time when everyone had the
Black Plague knee-slapping riot that one
you'd actually have to have been at the
Black Plague the first time and
intentionally set up a wormhole for
yourself so you can come back and relive
those beautiful moments of pustular
swelling a wormhole is basically just
like a glorified web browser bookmark
like the watch later tab or the youtube
subscribe button letting you earmark
moments in time you might want to come
back to later but if you've never been
there before there's no way you could
create the wormhole you need and there's
no solid evidence of the doctors setting
up wormholes as little reminders to
themselves to come back later quite
honestly it's really difficult to
believe that the doctor could actually
be able to use a wormhole to travel back
in time so despite the fact that doctor
who seems to use wormholes as his mail
tube through space-time according to
modern physics without that initial
wormhole being created as early in time
as possible there are just certain
moments in time the doctor wouldn't be
able to access again is it possible that
because the doctor is a Time Lord he was
actually there and all those other times
the set of wormholes yes I mean let's
face it this is a fantasy show where
anything's possible but we're gonna rule
it out because we'd never see direct
evidence that he does it in the series
so okay no wormholes but what if it were
something else something that looked
similar but functions slightly
differently well it turns out that I'm
not the only one interested in trying to
get the TARDIS through time recently two
physicists and fellow Time Lord
aficionados been tippet and David sang
of the Gallifrey Polytechnic Institute
and Gallifrey Institute of Technology
otherwise known as dal Tech Caltech
sounds just like a super geeky tinder Oh
her bose-einstein condensate is nowhere
close to absolute zero to wipe left
it's also worth pointing out that those
aren't real institutions they're
references to the show anyway they wrote
a paper called transversal a chronal
retrograde domains in space-time or
TARDIS I see what you guys did there to
show how the doctors time-travelling
blue box could actually exist in our
universe in theory in film theory it's
more of a tv-show theory but we're
talking about it now the paper shows how
traveling
pack up your own time stream is possible
inside the TARDIS using what's known as
a tippler cylinder no not tipper
cylinders but good early two-thousands
political reference there that was a
joke for the old people
a tippler cylinder is actually a whole
nother level of physic see weirdness and
was actually really challenging to
research but i think it provides an
interesting explanation for our Whovian
conundrum a tippler cylinder is
literally a cylinder of space-time which
interesting looks a lot like our
wormhole from earlier on but actually
has different properties for matter that
travels through it the cylinder itself
is made up of lots and lots of dense
mass including positive and negative
matter our Whovian physicists explained
that the TARDISes ability to move
through a Tipler cylinder depends on the
angle at which you enter the cylinder if
you enter it straight on then you're
kind of screwed because you're headed
straight for the central point of
gravity way in the center in this thing
so that once you enter you're unable to
leave without literally going faster
than the speed of light not ideal but
what if you enter it at an angle models
of Tipler cylinders today theorized that
if you enter the cylinder on an angle
remember this is an angle of not just
space with space-time that you'd be able
to escape being caught in the cylinder
forever instead you basically surf
across the inside of the cylinder at an
angle and end up in a position where you
actually continue following the curve of
the cylinder backwards in time because
that makes a whole lot of sense
essentially the TARDIS would be riding a
curve of time or what's known in quantum
physics as a closed time curve or CTC a
CTC would allow the TARDIS to escape
getting crushed forever in the mass of
the cylinder and explore any number of
infinite time curves all around the
Tipler cylinder so unlike our wormhole
before the TARDIS isn't trying to travel
through it it's trying to curve around
it you can even see this in the opening
sequence that the TARDIS isn't really
moving in a straight line it moves at
angles this just looks like an
accidental or stylistic choice but it
actually corresponds well with the turns
and angles you would need while
traveling at relativistic speeds through
a tippler cylinder to successfully
travel back in time
so the
next time you hear about the doctor
traveling through a wormhole to go save
the galaxy remember that he's actually
hopping into a tippler cylinder and
surfing across the surface of space time
to go save the galaxy if you didn't
understand any of that last paragraph I
don't blame you theoretical physics is
weird I'm still trying to wrap my head
around a lot of this stuff but it's a
cool thing to whip out at a party in a
conversation tell that to your friends
it'll make you seem smart and super cool
well you know it'll make it seem smart
let's just stick with smart so
shockingly after two rounds the score
still stands in favor of the existence
of Time Lord and if you think we're done
here you should be right but we're not
because history actually has reports of
one man who has mysteriously seemed to
be a Time Lord in disguise we're
actually gonna talk about him the
mysterious real-life doctor next time I
guess if they can go through 12 doctors
I can go through three episodes that's
only fair
so in the meantime remember that's just
a theory a quantum mechanical paradox
theory and cut physicists cannot say the
word physicists physicists hey do you
like the opening theme to film theory or
honestly a lot of the tracks that we use
across both game theorists and film
theorists then please do yourself a
favor and check out my dear friend karf
Darko he's been kind enough to support
game fear in film theory as well as all
the other shows on both channels for
what like nearly three years now with
his incredible musical talents so if you
need some catchy tunes to rock out to or
work out to working out that just ain't
me but hey if you're doing it more power
to you I support your struggle then
please go check out his channel by
clicking right here this is a man who
truly puts his everything into every
piece of music that he puts out so give
him some support his talent and
dedication make it more than worth your
time and once you've done that click
here to check out our first episode on
Doctor Who covering some crazy
biological things like the fact that you
yes you dear viewer had two hearts at
one point in your life
wild right or if you're into the science
stuff and saw that one click
to check out how Dragon Ball Z
characters perform energy waves there's
a lot of really awesome matter physics
in that one still working on harnessing
my ki energy and I think that's about it
so now if you'll excuse me I need to go
take some medicine hmm red pill or blue
pill